6 43 time to see what is trending with
Las Vegas now host and vgk uh fan Super
Fan Mercedes Martinez yeah there's so
much trending Mercedes joining in the
Mix 94.1
cities how do we boil it down to just
such a small segment
oh I know there is so much going on of
course thank you guys for letting me
come on and talk about it apparently it
is goodbye Las Vegas for Celine Dion
Radar Online is reporting that the
singing Megastar recently sold her local
Mansion for 30 million dollars with
plans to move back to our native Canada
now this after Celine canceled the
remainder of her recent tour due to
stiff person syndrome sources close to
the singer say that she wants to
surround herself with her friends and
family as she deals with the disease
also trending this morning big news from
a show you can see right here on channel
8. Pat Sajak has announced that after
next season he will be retiring from
Wheel of Fortune Sajak has hosted the
show for more than 40 years he made the
announcement on Twitter of course you
will be able to see his final shows
right here on 8 news now Heather John oh
that's it it's kind of the end of the
era for both Celine and
yeah okay let's change gears a little
bit uh Happy Meals one of my favorite
things as a kid actually probably still
would love to have a Happy Meal I just
haven't had one in a while it's the toy
though it was the toy that did it
Mercedes
yes absolutely beware if you have kids
you might want to cover their ears have
you ever heard of squishmallows oh they
are soft squishy toys that come in all
shapes and sizes in the form of animals
and Foods well McDonald's revealed the
squishmallow Happy Meal toys that will
soon add to restaurants Nationwide there
are 24 total including exclusive designs
only available through Mickey D's now
each restaurant will only have between
10 and 12 of them so you'll have to
visit more than once to collect them all
14 of them also include a playlist that
matches their personality now McDonald's
has not announced an official release
date yet but you can bet there's going
to be a lot of parents standing in line
oh my gosh squish mellow yeah is there
anything all over the bottom of your car
and stuff they're everywhere right